hey everybody and welcome to a smokin
wild ride with stevo we've got jackass
star rachel wolfson who loves to smoke a
lot of weed and who anybody would agree
is smoking hot so man do we get into it
just details about jackass about the the
all cast jackass text thread about the
business the finance
man i might have shared too much on this
episode but hey that's what i do i'm not
afraid of sharing too much and i'm not
afraid of telling you how important it
is to take a dump
with
your body bent but what i mean by that
is that our
genetics the human body was designed to
take a dump while crouching that's how
we do it in the woods like this right
it's not natural to sit on a toilet with
your feet on the ground and that's why
to replicate the position that your body
should be in to take a complete dump you
gotta have squatty potty this is a stool
that goes in front of your toilet that
elevates your feet so that you're taking
a dump crouching in a way that is good
for your colon health not only good for
your colon health but super important
for your health plus it's way more
satisfying to take a complete dump
so i want you guys to try squatty potty
i've sworn by it for gosh
10 years now i've been using this and i
love it my butthole loves it and your
butthole is going to love it too now if
you go to squattypotty.como
you can get
your own with 20 off because
that's how cool they are so please
support the podcast go to
squattypotty.com
stevo get 20 off your order and treat
your colon and your butthole with
respect
now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen rachel wolfson
yeah dude pound it
i don't have to introduce you to the
international star star randolph yep hi
scott hi nice to see you again nice to
see you guys scott's got his best like
dad outfit all he's missing is a cigar
right now he like looks retired
i'm like the uh the 2022 magnum pi i
love it you're ready i'm going for the
chest hair look you look like you should
be on a yacht right now it should be on
the audio
yes um so can we start off with any
abortion jokes oh my god please uh get
rid of those immediately yeah that's my
joke
please when in doubt pull out yeah yeah
i like chris pontius's um advice to the
high school
uh graduating class he says a vagina is
no place for semen oh well he is not
without consent
yeah and i liked uh your role saying
like dude we should start out every male
that's born get them a vasectomy if they
decide to have kids they should take a
class
and they should redo that and then they
should have kids well my argument was
that people should um
have to get a license in order to become
parents at least like a mental health
check
right i mean you gotta get a license to
catch a fish or get a gun or drive a car
right yeah that seems fair
i can't have a kid you should probably
take a test you get pulled over for
being a bad parent they're like show me
your license and registration it's just
like you have a kid that's just like
first time having sex like i feel so
good i don't want to stop
a [ __ ] kid yeah
like who wouldn't stop it feels so good
i mean i think stevo needs to have his
own birth control branded his own plan b
we uh we know how it went with uh stevo
condoms oh yeah that that was yeah you
actually got people pregnant actually
there are people out there who have kids
because of you
yeah i don't know i never actually sold
any condoms so thank god i have no uh
culpability for any pregnancies
and uh i personally got a vasectomy so i
don't have to worry about
how long did you have to wait until you
busted a nut after having a vasectomy
ah
you think stevo waited i don't think
the guy has the record
for the longest wait
well right um
but uh i didn't i think that the weight
they said don't do any strenuous
activity and we know how to handle that
yeah well but but this isn't about me
scott we we've got uh uh
rachel wolfson the the first
official jackass cast member hell yeah
with the vagina yes well that we know of
[Laughter]
um
so uh
it's great too you know that we're both
in
the the jackass world and the world of
just sort of comedy
and how uh
how beloved you are in both oh thank you
yeah that's so nice that and means a lot
from you sibo i really look up to you in
in both worlds just for the record wow
not just jackass it's a rare stand-up
who says that
i mean honestly like i don't give a [ __ ]
like [ __ ] what any hater says what
you've been able to do and what you do
is different it's a one-man show it's
comedic it's visually entertaining you
make men throw up what more and pass out
as and pass out as an audience member
asked from you i mean you entertained
yeah well thank you i i appreciate that
a lot your true showman um are we seeing
the uh
the effects of jackass forever and
jackass 4.5
um manifest as ticket sales for your
comedy i mean i just did
three shows in phoenix this weekend with
matt we had like 255 people come out
over the course of three shows i don't
know anyone in phoenix so for me if i
sell one ticket i'm stoked on that
that's cool and we had you know 255
people so i'm starting to sell tickets
in places that i've never been to and
that i don't know
people in and to me that's a success for
me because i'm in a building phase sure
what do they uh
come up to you and say more i saw you in
uh forever or 4.5 ooh um i think forever
i think people are still just getting
around to seeing 4.5 because there
wasn't that much promotion behind
4.5 i feel like like 4.5 kind of just
dropped on netflix and like not everyone
has a netflix account yeah but i'm what
i am getting feedback is is people
enjoyed 4.5 almost more or just as much
as they looked forever yeah
i i haven't heard a lot of that too it's
weird i wish there was a way to
get accurate numbers on what the
aggregate viewing was for forever versus
4.5 because i got to believe
that
with covid fear fewer people were
willing to go to the movie theaters that
like the you know individually buying it
on demand like versus like the number of
people who have netflix
i think that uh
my money would say that more people saw
4.5 than forever yeah i think i think
i i mean i'm getting feedback for both i
just don't know what i'm getting more of
i i think they're just like i saw you in
jackass and like that's just right i'm
like i don't know which one but i the
feedback i'm getting about 4.5 is
everyone loves it they're stoked on it i
mean i think uh
yeah it's it's it's landed pretty well
it's a nice look at behind the scenes of
like what goes on
and how everything comes to fruition and
i think yeah i think it answered a lot
of questions for people of like how we
got here and like you know just some
things that after seeing forever that
maybe like they didn't right they were
wondering about you know
for sure um it had an narrative 4.5 that
um
that was uh
digestible it felt like a like a legit
story right
i had a really cool moment in phoenix we
had three girls come out who were very
much jackass fans and one of them
um
came up to me after and she was like i
don't want to get emotional like we were
you know talking after the show smoking
a joint doing molly yeah no
none of that but but definitely joints
and she was like you know it meant so
much to see a girl on jackass like i
grew up a jackass fan and finally there
was a girl and she got emotional and i
was like don't do this you know we can't
cry here but yeah it was really cool the
reaction's been so positive you know for
the most part and it's really cool to
see support from female fans as well you
know super cool were you nervous going
in like
like you had no idea what you were gonna
do like where'd your brain take you of
like oh [ __ ] they're gonna do some
gnarly [ __ ] or did you
just had no idea i literally had
no idea like even walking to set that
day there was no discussion about what i
would be even participating in what i
had no idea what stunts were being done
that day i didn't even know like
honestly what it was there
it's not that i didn't know i knew i was
like there to be work like i i honestly
i didn't know i just i just showed up
they sent me a shoot date
for the test shoot
um there were moments where like when we
started shooting you know jeff would say
to me don't volunteer for this or like
you know like
vol you know whatever so i would get
feedback along the way
i understood it that your role was to
kind of like
roast the the guys just kind of make fun
of the guys as they did their bits yeah
i mean i think that um like there wasn't
really any full discussion of what my
role was like i honestly thought
um i wanted to write
come right and be you know writing ideas
and stuff um
but i i mean the fact that i got to
participate that was you know a dream
come true i mean it was so cool um
and i think that my role kind of evolved
over time because i'm honestly not
naturally a roaster i don't like to be
mean and i don't i didn't i knew you
guys growing up in my bedroom or like in
my teeth in my lip but not in my bedroom
and under my bed sheets in my tv
in my tv you guys were in my house like
growing up and i know you as that
and i look up to you guys like you know
brothers um but also i didn't know you
guys like that so for me to roast you it
just seemed insulting i well i did have
that one joke you know i had the
diabetes joke that i dropped
but it just came out and it just felt so
natural and like it wasn't like
it was just preston zach was there
you know and i don't know i felt
i'm not a natural roaster unless it's
like about i know that that's it's weed
unless it's about me or i don't know but
or unless i know you very well and i
feel comfortable enough to like
roast you guys but even when i did drop
that joke it was a hit it was a hit but
it might have ruffled some feathers
we weren't that close you know like we
didn't it's weird coming in as a new
person and then here i am supposed to
make fun of you guys who've been family
for you know 20 years what day number
was this that you were one
that was on the test shoot and you know
i was not at when i dropped that when i
said that joke spike comes up to me and
he goes more of that and i was like okay
i think i got the idea of what i'm
supposed to be doing here so from that
point on just based off the feedback
from what some of the guys gave me it
was like just say as much as possible
but again i'm competing with 12 comedic
geniuses you know or at least like they
know what they're doing they know like
what well especially that's like their
home court right that's like
so yeah if there was any question about
whether you would be involved i know
that specifically the diabetes joke
really
secured your position well i think
at that point you guys kind of knew like
knoxville kind of saw my humor online
but it's different you can be funny
online does it transcend in person
how did knoxville find you
on my said instagram
yeah i had a joke um i don't know if it
was this one initially but i noticed
after like my oj joke got put up by the
laugh factory it got four million views
on instagram and i got 15 000 followers
and a bunch of like you know um bigger
accounts started following me and it was
around that time so i don't know if it
was initially that or if just the
algorithm brought me you know in front
of his algorithm
and yeah and then he just was very
supportive of my content on online and a
lot of it was
you know observational very much jackass
style you know butt stuff [ __ ] jokes dick
jokes
you know that
was very influential on my childhood
yeah
so so he sent you um it was his first
message about like hey we're gonna make
a new movie the message was
i will admit i was dying to hear the
story about knoxville sliding into
rachel's dms and thank god we get to
hear it all
and man i know that a bunch of you are
probably just watching because rachel's
attractive but please you gotta admit
i'm looking great too and you know why
it's because i'm taking care of my skin
baby with the best products out there
for skin care it's called geology
g e o l o g i e
geology.com is where you get it and man
are they going to hook you up if you go
to
geology.com and use the promo code stevo
you're going to get a five piece starter
kit valued at 50 bucks for just 15 bucks
and up to 70 off your 30-day trial
telling you that this geology eye cream
is the secret to success man the eyes
are the first things to go but not mine
because geology's got me covered so jump
on this deal support the podcast take
care of your skin reduce your acne get
rid of the oil and stave off the
wrinkling by going to
geology.com and using the promo code
stevo they're taking care of you so you
take care of them now let's hear about
those dms
hey
um
it was hey i wanna can i give you a call
i wanna
see if you're interested in something i
wanna talk to you it was like an initial
like i wanna see if you're interested in
something basically so i gave him my
number and then
like five minutes later he called me and
that's when he would he said it was an
anniversary special right i didn't know
it was a movie but whatever it was he
said it was jackass and as soon as i
heard jackass which in my heart i was
hoping he was saying which was you know
and he's like is that would you want to
come in for a meeting with me and jeff
and i was like yeah so i went in for the
meeting and all they said was
we're going to be shooting i think
initially in october
the first when they the first discussion
right but i ended up getting pushed way
way back right right it was december the
test yeah and would you want to come
play with us kind of thing and i was
like yeah but i didn't know what that
meant i just was down to clown like it
didn't matter but i did say i was like
hey if you guys have any writing
sessions like i would be so down to
participate because that's where my
strengths lie is in writing
so your boyfriend mm-hmm now you're
engaged no no just a point well pump
um so your boyfriend like
what was that conversation like you know
i got a dm from knoxville
you know we didn't uh matt and i started
dating maybe like um
a couple months after that
and i didn't tell anyone i didn't tell
i was going through a breakup at the
time and it was actually a really like
hopeful
thing in my life that i didn't i was
like i don't know if that's how this is
going to play out but i just received a
call from knoxville like i'm doing good
you know like [ __ ] that guy who who we
bro i broke up with oh okay um you know
and and so
it was um matt and i started dating in
july like right around this time three
years ago so that phone call was i think
may
right that's about it sounds about right
and so
you know i didn't tell him right off the
bat
because i'm not going to be like hey
just so you know right i just kind of
like casually as we got to know each
other
let him know that um i've been having
conversations but don't tell anyone
because sure did he get intimidated
no he was so stoked
her boyfriend's the man
i love him he's so nice he's and he
loves you guys and he grew up as much a
jackass fan as like all of us and i
think you know for him it's also he's a
comedian too so for him to see
a
young comedian come in hit the ground
running [ __ ] hustle like he knew and
saw me and heard about me before we
started dating and saw the content i put
online and even like was aware of oh wow
she's like in she's really good at this
internet stuff
and um he was stoked he was stoked cool
yeah how'd you guys meet did you slide
into your dms
actually i slid into his oh really yeah
i did um we met at the comedy store we
were both dating other people
and mutual friend introduced us and um
what'd you say
i said hey can you take this picture of
me and my hot friend like and he ended
up taking a selfie of himself
um so i had that picture of him
and
i think we didn't speak until maybe
three years after that yeah
um and i found out he is he had become
recently single and his mentor was jeff
garlin and he jeff is also a mentor of
mine um and
i
knew that so i hit up jeff and i was
like it was actually father's day and
jeff and i went and had lunch on
father's day and i was like hey you know
you're opener matt like what's his deal
and he was like oh it's perfect and nice
you know we ended up
meeting up after i love your boyfriend's
joke and by the way her boyfriend's name
is matt matt edgar yeah matt with one t
matt edgar he says uh you know dating
my girlfriend you know she's working on
jackass and you know people ask me like
man you must be like threatened like she
said they're going hanging around all
these naked dudes with their dicks out
and everything and he's like
well it does bother me because i want to
be there
like if i ever saw pontius's penis in
person i get star-strucked you know yeah
i'd ask for a dick pic
he's so stoked and it honestly it
wouldn't have worked out with me and
someone who wasn't supportive i would
have broken up with him and for sure
yeah yeah pontius must have the record
for like dick time on them
is it is that a real thing is somebody
look that up
but mr skin where are you at
yeah i mean that's like six seven
minutes of solid guinness book of world
records i know yeah
so
growing up with a uh a d.a as a father
and your
dad's a diego your mom's a judge right
she was a judge um she's now a mediator
but she was um the judge who put oj in
prison in las vegas judge edo
people are like your mom's judge edo i'm
like no my mom
but is is growing up with a like a da as
a father is like the same thing as like
being a preacher's daughter
do you get in trouble i mean would my
dad answer the door with a shotgun no um
it's i guess it would be
i guess i you would have to ask the men
who have tried to date me i don't know i
i it probably is intimidating i don't
think that that's the question more i
think he's saying like that are you wild
like a catholic oh oh oh because see i'm
jewish so i didn't get the joke um
but you grew up in vegas i mean were you
going i was definitely
you know i was like
i definitely
was a rambunctious kid i was a hyper kid
i had adhd as a kid i was diagnosed from
a very young age so
um i played sports like and i was always
getting in trouble in the principal's
office like i went to um
religious schools
um i went to a christian school in vegas
and i think that's how my mom tried to
like curb
my
you know wildness or at least prevent
because i didn't do
i wasn't like drinking or doing drugs
but
you know i would sneak out of the house
and
when when did you become such a pothead
you know it wasn't until i got to
college um
because you know i i had taken a lot of
pharmaceuticals
um you know i was diagnosed with
depression when i was 12
and from a very young age had taken
pharmaceuticals for a lot of my mental
health you know
like ritalin and i was on adderall i
started on adderall when i was five
wow did you ever snored it when you were
five
although if i did i would have been the
coolest kid for sure um but i uh
did it work like
it makes everybody else hyper and stay
awake you know how many businesses i had
when i was five years old
is that like what the deal is with
able to adhd
like at five i felt like you know um
yeah i could conquer the world but i'm
on legal
meth so yeah um yeah doing blow back in
the day like really like made me like
recluse and like inward i didn't get
hyper i mean i got hyper but like i just
i think that would be the same effect as
adhd medicaid like ritalin would make me
like real like i was very serious i
would be it would make me very irritable
um but i was i would hyper focus on
whatever they wanted me to focus on yeah
so yeah so when i was 19 i went away to
college and a boyfriend of mine smoked
weed
and i was still on pharmaceuticals at
the time
and i i tried it and i remember liking
the way it made me feel it just made me
feel
i don't know better
so
and then did you stop the medication or
do you still eventually i came off the
pharmaceuticals i was 23 when i came off
and
that did that suck
um it wasn't
like it wasn't as bad as it could have
been because i did it with the advice of
a doctor i was like how do i taper down
with support and i wanted everyone to
know like i did it the way that you're
supposed to do it i'm like i'm not gonna
just [ __ ] around with this because if
certain medications that i was on if you
come off you can have a seizure
um certain medications i was on if you
don't take it the right way you can
develop a deadly rash i mean this stuff
is gnarly um so yeah and i i came off
and i've been off since i was 20
um three years old i believe
wow or sorry i was excuse me i was 26
i believe yeah
all right
what can you tell everybody about
the crazy jackass cast thread
honestly like when i received the text
from you guys in my mind i'm like
if only people knew the fl like what i
what i see what goes on the
conversations i feel so blessed to be a
part of it it's pretty gnarly and the
access to early content drops i mean
i really i i'm so happy i get to be a
part of this chat and this you know this
family but yeah uh it really is a
special thread
except i think
poopy's kind of abusive he really does
and he should only like poopy should
only be able to promote like one piece
of content
i mean promote content also and you know
like there's other certain
pieces of content we receive from
poopies that no one should see no one
can
talk about it i mean i don't even
i don't think we should talk about it
it's nothing like illegal um it's just
criminally boring
[Laughter]
it is uh i wish that there was a way to
revoke poopy's
um
access to this thread on center you know
like there should be like censor like
there's you know how you can censor the
words you see on twitter and social
media
and the content you see it's not a bad
idea but i mean let's not create the
impression that uh that i'm mad at
poopies no we love cookies he's
he's he's very uh innocent in in
his own little way like
he's uh
he's he's a special guy in the eyes of
the lord maybe but nothing on anyone
else's eyes right but but it's a lot of
fun and i bring it up because you're so
classic in that thread like oh thank you
whenever
it it gets a certain point like there's
13 people in the thread so you've got
every single cast member old and new
except we man opted out i didn't even
realize that until uh dave england told
me what he meant in it yeah he left
women's hasn't been in it for like i
thought he was the navy he just doesn't
respond
oh no aaron barely responds yeah and uh
but everybody's in it tremaine's in it
you know knoxville like
um and and we'll get into this like
everyone's throwing in like zingers and
like it's a joke and it's almost a joke
off and virtually 100 of the time rachel
like chimes in with the funniest oh
thank you it's so fun to be a part of
it's fun it's fun i i definitely i will
say in the group chat poopy's butthole
has
made up made an appearance yeah yeah we
all know it's not pretty's butthole as
much as the balloon knot attached to it
right
what it's um
some would say it's art i don't know why
did he send that
say that
it's not that he didn't send it it's
just uh he made an appearance
his butthole has been revealed on set
and it's become the stuff of legends
and it gets referred to um
quite often
it's
i didn't know i was part of the cast
until like after we shot the movie you
know what i mean like there was a
conversation after where like they were
like oh you're an official cast member
because like right i didn't an opening
credit right and i i you know i was just
grateful to be there and to have that
experience and to work with you guys so
that's how i'm always approaching any
situation how has your life changed
before and after
you know i don't
to me it's like hard for me to see
other than like obviously my social
media following has increased but like
i'm not like i was never one to like
i guess like
i still feel the same like i'm still
doing the same thing i still go to the
same open mics i still hang out with the
same people
you know i'm not like flying around on
private jets i don't have like a million
dollars or more dudes sliding into your
dm 100 i guess i got different oh my god
that reminds me dude she gets the
craziest [ __ ] damn dude the dms that
she gets everyone wants me to do like
everyone wants me to like put your hot
sauce in my butthole for some reason
like my butthole is just like a huge
topic of conversation in the dm you want
to put the hot sauce for your butthole
in your butthole they want they they're
they want it i don't know rachel
started
an a separate instagram account strictly
for the most hilarious dms she receives
and you just post them yeah she really
anonymously because she respectfully
blurs out like the handles so she's not
there
there are wives and kids involved i'm
sure you know yeah but dude like there's
[ __ ] like i i wanna eat cereal out of
your booty hole
and so i called them my new pebbles why
is it all about your butthole well not
all of them are actually i do get some
wholesome messages like i got this
message from this guy my mom sent to
prison years ago but he was like to be
fair he was like listen your mom gave me
so many chances i went through her court
i couldn't get sober but because of her
i got sober because he finally got his
life together it took like seven times
that wouldn't have made the wolfy dm it
did
it did make the wolfy dms because it was
so outrageous that my mom had you know
sent this guy to prison and here he is
one saying so nice things about her
and saying how much of a jackass fan he
was that one because i like to make i
don't want it to always be sexual
because like it's that's just like an
easy grab
i think like okay and i think maybe i do
remember that yeah but so i mix it up
some are i throw some wholesome ones
what's the worst one you've gotten um
what's the what's the link so people can
go check it out it's wolfie dms
w-o-l-f-i-e-d-m
stevo's has been a supporter pretty much
since the beginning so i thank you for
that
what can i say i'm a fan of filthy dms
that make me laugh and rachel supplies
them on the regular now you know what
else i'm a fan of doing business online
selling merch just last week we did this
uh post malone video where we did a
limited pre-order for t-shirts and i'm
going to tell you candidly we sold a
whole lot of t-shirts we actually
put ourselves in a position of sending
out
over a thousand packages
in one day
and that is a lot but it's easy for us
because we use ship station that's how
we run my entire
e-commerce operation is with shipstation
it's
one interface which integrates all of
your different platforms that you sell
on if it's on amazon etsy your own
website doesn't matter it's all just
funneled into one place as well as all
of the different shipping carriers like
the united states post office ups
fedex see what i'm saying plus they give
you the best rates
for shipping which are usually reserved
for fortune 500 companies you get the
best deals and
you print out your labels slap them on
the package ready to go it makes
shipping so easy that's how we do it
that's how we ship thousands of packages
in a single day
and you can get a 60-day free trial you
can try this service for absolutely
nothing for an entire 60 days and you
too can be
shipping stuff like crazy
and it's so easy so to get this offer
you go to shipstation.com
and when the website loads click in the
top right corner you click on the
microphone you type in the promo code
stevo and you're set up to try 60 days
of absolutely free
hassle-free
super easy shipping enjoying such low
rates you can't beat it so jump into the
business game by selling merch online
with shipstation make ship happen baby
by going to shipstation.com
click the road the microphone in the top
right corner type in the promo code
stevo and get to work now let's talk
more about these dms
um you know i just someone said i no
that one's inspirational um
you know
he's jacking off giving you a quote
people are like
um uh
oh no okay this was bruh i would love to
lick whipped cream out of your beautiful
magnificent and exquisite booty hole i
don't know why they're obsessed with my
butthole um and how do they know it's so
exquisite i know and someone somewhat
like people are really they're like i'd
let you ruin my life um oh oh if you
were my mom i'd still smash that was
one of the worst ones
um it's pretty epic yeah um but yeah i
mean
oh yeah just a lot of
a lot of really you know horrible good
great things in there so um
have you uh
like
done a lot of hard drugs
not as much as i think people think i've
done i'm not really into drugs like i'm
really just into what makes me feel
balance you know like
normal i guess or as normal as i can get
well well i mean what kind of drugs have
you done like i i've done molly before
i've done bad molly and that was enough
to never make me want to do it again
like once you do the bad version of the
drug you think you're doing normally
that would make you want to stop well
for me it makes me never want to do it
again yeah that's an issue i never asked
you about you ever done a drug where
you're like oh [ __ ] i shouldn't have
done that or you were just like yes like
when i drank aluminum cleaner oh my god
what i think that's what it was that i
got it was some like aluminum cleaner
[ __ ] and i [ __ ] couldn't get off the
kitchen floor like well because you told
me about a time when you were in new
york and you just felt like you were
free-falling and like
i was in london england that was on
ketamine that sounds
horrible i friends who would do that in
college and just do it in their dorm
rooms it was it was the greatest ever
you're you're snorting ketamine and also
you're done snorting and you're like
i'm just like so
utterly [ __ ] up on ketamine that the
hotel room i was in
just started free falling and like i i
was like
looked up and it was like the
i was looking up at like a shaft that it
was falling through it was the greatest
thing that ever happened while that was
happening you were like [ __ ] yes i was
like this is the raddest [ __ ] thing i
would have freaked dude see that stuff
scares me i think cause like i think
because i was forced to take
pills
growing as a kid there's never i i don't
have that desire so much to do
like there's i don't i don't really do
that many drugs like i've done coke i've
done
once
you know i've done mushrooms here and
there
but i really just like weed
lsd
no molly that was it all right heroin no
no never never had the urge so um you
were on the jimmy kimmel show yeah
the and uh was that to promote the movie
it was
to promote the movie that was in
february
epic
it was epic that was also another
surreal moment i mean yeah these
i guess because it's been so much time i
forgot like all the stuff that happened
directly after the movie came out like
that was such a cool moment hanging with
kimmel and um doing that show and he's
such a
big supporter of vegas and obviously
comedy so
um yeah huge fan
and what other big shows to everybody um
i did watch what happens live with andy
cohen the yeah that's bravo the
pressure's podcast i did bert's podcast
love bert and i love how much he loves
jackass and all of you guys
and he's so supportive of us so he's the
best
um weren't you on um
like was it wendy williams or um no no i
didn't do wendy williams i was on i
think it was um
uh
who's podcast
um
i don't know i mean i did uncle joey's
podcast
um
i'm it's been like a while so i haven't
it's been so long i haven't um i can't
remember i did a bunch of promotion
right after
the the movie that was so fun yeah yeah
wow what a trip yeah
life-changing literally and it it's it's
crazy because i feel like i
my situation i got into stand up
2016
and i book a movie
2019 three years into my stand-up career
i mean that is
i never got into stand-up to get into
movies i got into stand-up to learn the
art of stand-up and and the fact that i
even
was able to
get here is so cool to me and i'm so
grateful for you guys and i try to tell
knoxville you know like any time i can
because i am so like i i just i'm so
stoked i got to have that experience
with all of you yeah well i'm grateful
to you i mean when uh
whenever i've reached out like you've
always just been been all about it i was
like hey can can you guys come over and
uh you know watch a recording of my live
show and give me notes and stuff
i'm team stevo so whatever whatever you
need stevo i got you what day number did
you
guys do the mind bit was that right off
the bat or was that well into it yeah
see that's the stuff like later on
because you know covid hit and there was
i think they had other ideas maybe you
know nothing official but remember like
covet hit like
and then we had to readjust some things
i think a lot of the stuff i think they
ended up being able to do but there's
probably stuff that we
that might have been done had covered
not happened
um you know so yeah i mean it was really
quick and they had two days for the test
shoot then there was one week of filming
principal photography before covert shut
everything down so basically
you know i mean it's pretty incredible
how much of those two days of test
footage made the movie yeah that was
that wasn't that's actually oh that's
insane that was test footage the the
mind
but a lot of the stuff in forever and in
4.5 are from the test shoots it made the
movie yeah like almost everything that
you guys shot
did you know the day of that you're
gonna lick the taser or did you
really just know in real time that it
was gonna happen um no jeff called me
and both the times with the scorpion and
the taser they asked if i would be down
and i said yeah
i would be down they actually asked me
if i initially would be down to do do
the snake poopies
and i said i would i was down it was
pretty rad how like being there how well
you handled licking a taser i would have
been a super [ __ ] about that
you never looked and she did over and
over and over that's what people don't
always understand is that when we shoot
something you see it happen once but in
reality it happened over and over and
over yeah that's what jeff likes to do
well how many
how many times did you get stung by the
scorpion that we didn't see oh a lot
yeah we use like three different
scorpions the one that we saw isn't even
the most painful one that one just like
hurts a little bit but there was this
one that was super tiny um i forget what
the smaller the scorpion the gnarlier it
was small it was translucent but it was
harder to see on film
but that one was so painful that's the
one you actually see me reacting to at
the end where i'm starting to sweat
starting to sweat
um yeah that and that i just let them
because they wanted to see my lip puff
up like cartoon sure but it i did my
body didn't react that way i mean it
puffed up but not cartoon
i feel like you've been bitten by or
stung by a lot of scorpions yep a lot of
them like how many would you say
i mean the first time uh
was when i was on tour
in like
2003
with the african emperor scorpions then
we actually went to africa and
restaurant with a bunch of scorpions is
that the small one
the african the african emperor one is
the black one okay that's the one that
they shot yeah that one's still not
great but
yeah not as painful as the small ones um
[ __ ] that yeah
um
with uh
is it true
of course it's true that um that after
the fact you guys got your deals all the
new people and it was like they're going
to pay you the least amount of money
that they legally can to be a principal
cast member but then after the fact and
after the movie came out they came to
you and said hey we're going to give you
guys participation in the back end um
okay so i
don't know what everyone else's
discussions were because again my
situation was different i wasn't like
from the beginning i didn't know i was
an official
cast member so the the payments i were
receiving were just like
i wasn't sag yet so they just paid me a
certain amount every two weeks and as a
comedian i'm just stoked to
see it and i'm just stoked to be working
so to me it didn't seem like out of the
ordinary i also didn't have reps when i
i booked jackass on my own so like i
didn't have to cut anyone 20 or anything
so again like i was just stoked to be
working um at the end
when um
when we kept getting word that the movie
release was pushed back there was a
conversation were you on the call for
that one i don't think exactly i
remember when they they had
like uh one call for og cash and one
call yeah i'm sure um so yeah there was
a conversation with all of us where
um
they announced that it wasn't gonna be
october it was pushed to february yeah
and that was like man i mean after
like for us you guys are you guys are
all
it's okay when it comes out comes out
but for us new cast members i mean this
is like
the beginning of the rest of our careers
of our lives like the pandemic hits we
need some good news and when they came
to us and told us it was gonna be like
another six months it was just like oh
my god what are we gonna do you know it
was so funny on our call
it was just the o.g guys and uh spike
and um tremaine and like whoever's
speaking like that's the what the screen
shows it was so funny because uh
tremaine says like
they're pushing the release date to
february and and then all of a sudden
the screen turns into dave england going
yeah
and then the screen becomes me i'm like
dave what are you talking about i was
like
you know the the the the trailers out
yeah there's a big buzz around it and
this the second this movie comes out
it's old news
and where washed up has been no you're
right it actually ended up it that was
the beautiful part is in retrospect it
ended up working out in our favor
and so much better because there was so
much more promotion
it like people felt like you know
there was a buzz around the whole thing
and i was like as soon as it comes out
we're over like old news by by delaying
the release to
like you know months down the road we're
extending this period of time that we're
like hot [ __ ] that has a buzz around us
right and uh and then and then you see
spike he's like wow i never thought of
it that way and then you see tremaine i
need everybody to be on their best to be
yeah that's what i honestly think that's
the most
about poopies has six months more could
not [ __ ] this up no i mean honestly like
it it ended up working out um for all of
us and and it was like such a
nice surprise any extra information that
we got about you know financial for sure
so again like i'm just grateful and yeah
i mean i was i'm just stoked
i mean yeah i heard that it was like
after the fact after i think maybe even
after the movie came out and they said
like hey we're gonna we're gonna give
you guys participation
that was before actually that was before
the movie came out but it was during
that call when they said they were going
to push
to keep us from not killing ourselves um
rachel's like wait what i was like
people were getting participation points
well i just i
didn't i didn't i didn't i just was
stoked i just was stoked well i know and
i i just i bring that up because i was
personally
really impressed and happy to hear that
you know like
you know
over the years going back to the
beginning like you know try trying to
get paid
like it wasn't a real easy thing yeah
and uh for them to offer that up to you
guys when they really didn't have to
like i i just wanted to uh
to tell them like guys that's [ __ ]
cool of you and
i mean of course like we've heard the
stories about how you know how it was
before and right like
it is different now and we are a new
cast and we we do have it different than
you guys and
in a sense of like how things are just
because we're the new generation and you
kind of like laid it down you know like
pave the path for us so you did it's
almost like being the firstborn you know
the second the baby kind of gets you
know treated a little bit better um and
so my experience has only been positive
like throughout the whole thing i have
nothing bad to say like about anything
that happened not that like you were
implying that or anything but it's i
think in hollywood it's so rare to have
that experience especially on an
all-male cast right being the only
female you know well yeah and and gender
aside the reality is that you know
people would line up for miles to be
able to be in a jackass movie you know
like i get a lot of submission tapes
you can argue that there's like
so
many people would want to be in a
jackass movie regardless of whether they
got paid that
it's almost like they don't have to pay
right but to be in it well
that's totally like i mean coming from a
comedy place like we do a lot of stuff
for free in the beginning yeah and
that's what i'm saying like
i was just even shocked that i was even
my name was thrown in the hat for this
because you know i'm not a pro skater i
don't have that background my background
is comedy which is what you guys do so
you know like
i still can't believe even to this day
that
i was able to be a part of it so i am
still very stoked on it and it's still
very cool to me and that i hope that i
hope that shine never dims you know for
sure no i think it won't you have a
great attitude thank you everyone's
super stoked and and uh
you know you you earned the spot i mean
everybody earned it and you know like i
said they didn't even have to
give you anything and and they did and i
was really impressed yeah so it's you
know and i yeah i i just feel
really good about the whole thing so do
you have a favorite jackass for a bit
forever
um obviously anyone that i'm right no
but um
honestly like silence of the lambs was
incredible i think that's the hardest i
ever laughed oh man
just like dave's reactions and pontius
like being like the crazy the music
it's so good and
it's i mean dark shark's so amazing he's
so funny and just seeing his reactions
and situations the fear luck oh yeah um
obviously any bit steve owes in is
iconic and legendary
um
yeah i mean
it was just so fun like i it's like
being at disneyland as an adult because
when you leave set you're like wow what
was that you know reality sets back in
yeah it's so funny like some of the most
[ __ ] up stuff happened to you and like
you couldn't talk about it and then you
would come here to film a podcast and
we're like oh how was your day today and
you're like that was cool
and then like
then seeing the movie you're like oh
[ __ ] like that's what you were doing
like it's so hard to keep it secret for
years like just act like like just live
my life you know yeah well people kept
people kept wondering why steve
was looking like the dude from tiger
king jeff with the headband on it yeah
yeah every podcast we did he had the
head the
headphones yeah yeah i mean it's just so
classic that
in the middle of principle of
photography like what director is like
okay yeah let's rip stevo's eyebrows off
especially when the when the whole idea
was that we were gonna tattoo a penis on
my [ __ ] forehead where the eyebrow
was and you guys never did that
like uh at the very last second
knoxville was like there's too much dick
stuff we're not
that's the one they decide to pull out
from
like no that's i mean i'm still gonna
get a dick tattooed on my forehead but
uh
but yeah it's just it's just crazy that
via that that uh
all right there was no explanation for
why i was the the steve lowe
steve
or jeff lowe that's so funny steve lowe
yeah
i like it do you have any shows coming
up
um yeah i have dates i'm gonna be
in new york um july 31st at the stand i
got my own
um show there
i have dates in tampa orlando and miami
in august on my website i have dates in
um austin in november at
your website uh rachelwolfsoncomedy.com
let me just make sure
yeah it's rachel wolfson comedy also
stevo's been such an inspiration for
like
rachelwolfsoncomedy.com seeing like his
websites and
what he did to knoxville's website
art
um yeah so honestly i really look up to
you and like a lot of us comedians do
and and like what you've done
as yourself is it's incredible so it's
really cool to have someone to look up
to
thank you
um i had set you up with scott on uh
text to get you going with um
some merch yeah i've um i've been
struggling with my merch because every i
just every merch person either ghost me
not that sheila ghost me but like i
don't know i've just been struggling do
you have designs um i have some designs
but that's what i need help with
essentially um but yeah i have
i just i'm in like a crisis with my
merch let's get you set up yeah i mean i
think that we've got a fairly large
audience we get like poopy's merch is
dope and if poopy's merch can be dope
mine can be mediocre
it's so funny like the the stuff that
we've done for
you know
helping the guys get on their feet
no we need it we don't like we
you you realize like before this you
know poopies was just like a he's not a
marketing person like you know
well you know he doesn't he doesn't you
know we're learning as we go in some of
these things like we were we were so
ready to help poopies we're like okay we
got these designs made no no poopies
we're like we're gonna uh we're gonna
order like this many shirts we're gonna
help you um like
with your online store putting it
together fulfilling the orders
poopies was not able to respond to any
emails from the people who were trying
to make
like produce his shirts he needs an
assistant
he needs a number two
now i feel like i can roast poopies
because i know you know what i mean we
can say we can say we can you know but
um but we should absolutely like yeah
i need help i just have one shirt on my
website that's i had designs none of
them sold they've been up for months and
then we know for a fact that rachel
wolfson
checks her dms
so i do
let's enlist some help from all of the
graphic designers out there in the
audience i do i want to say like i do
get a lot of really great art made i'm
sure you've seen because we get made by
the same artists and stuff there's a lot
of people who are willing who do design
and do stuff and i am grateful for all
of them and i have some designs made
from them and stuff but you know i'm
open to
my merch direction cool yeah happy to
help
yeah thank you guys for sure so we've
covered your uh your upcoming shows yeah
we've got uh we've got your dm instagram
but what's your is your normal instagram
just rachel wolfson yeah it's rachel
wolfson i got my own name on instagram
so it's official nice do you have the
check mark i do i got a blue check i
just got a blue check mark on tick tock
although i have no idea what i'm doing
there
i love tick tocks
obsessed with your time you're on tick
tock dude i love tick tock it's the best
thing that's ever happened in my life
really i'm just kidding oh no but no i
do like it i believe it like there's you
could be the biggest star in tik tok i
wouldn't even know i just reposted these
clips and like okay i have like 86 000
followers
really it just it just starts going ape
[ __ ] oh my god scott randolph 83
i think it's because he's really
attractive yeah i mean i've lost 30
pounds i feel good you are looking
really good is it the hawaiian shirt or
is it the cologne that i'm saying
your your skin is glowing
i've been playing tennis
not pickleball nope i've been playing
tennis lose weight do cardio my sister
once described you as uncomfortably
attractive wow
really well move over paul briskey
i mean dude you're you're uh you're
gaining on him yeah i'm certainly
gaining on him and with this video
coming out tomorrow i'm going to be a
certified star yeah you are ah
okay so
your social media i'm just agreeing with
you
we've got your website
rachelwolfsoncomedy.com
your main instagram rachel wolfson yeah
your unbelievably entertaining wolfy dms
thank you
and your upcoming shows is there
anything else
just stay perched for my journey yeah
because i'm not saying like you know
i i'm never i just follow me along as i
become a beast that's hopefully stay
purged yeah i like that i love it
that's cool all right good well thank
you so much for for coming and doing you
guys thank you for having me that was
fun so fun yeah
could rachel be any more likable i mean
don't you just want to see her kick ass
aren't you rooting for i know i am and i
love to see all the comedians just
saying wonderful things about her i love
watching her become more successful in
her career
and uh it's just great to see it happen
i also think i might have actually over
shared on that episode uh i got a little
bit nervous about putting this one out i
mean i don't know
what
i'm sure it'll be fine i'm just an
honest guy i'm a candid guy i speak the
truth and the truth is i'm grateful for
you sticking around to the end of this
podcast and if i'm really truthful i'm
even more grateful if you had pre-order
my book if you haven't already
pre-ordered my new book please do that
like the pre-orders are so important to
how the book
does how it's received and
if you
go to stevo.com at the top of the
website it says pre-order my new book
then click it and pick the right
distributor for the signed copy because
i'm signing like a madman over here um
just want to put it out there man i love
you guys and god i would appreciate it
if you pre-order my new book and that's
enough for me thank you i love you all
yeah dude